et nous sommes de retour tout comme les cinq
mousquetaires
trois mousquetaires un nom eh bien personne ne
sait combien de personnes dans le monde
savent vraiment que les trois mousquetaires sont une
fiction écrite par Alexandre
Dumas beaucoup de gens disent cela à propos de
la Bible ces jours-ci  qu'est-ce que c'était
écrit par un Xander Dumas oh ne sois pas
idiot Steve c'était écrit par Jésus ils
ne se sont pas vus depuis 20 ans je suis
libre de faire ce que ha ha mais ce soir
ils retournent dans leur ville natale pour
terminer l'ultime tournée des pubs c'est
notre chance de conquérir enfin le Golden
Mile douze pubs douze pintes et cette
fois ils vont se rendre au
dernier pub du bout du monde
recommanderez-vous ouais
pour ceux Gary willkommen Bienvenue
bienvenue
qui revient bizarrement  et tout est
si différent je vous suggère de vous mettre en
route
bienvenue à la maison les garçons ça a changé
nous faisons ça va
auquel cas je vous le dirai
après dites moi tout de suite
qu'avez-vous dit monsieur Newton Haven a été
pris en charge par des robots l'avez-vous cru
hé nous sommes tous ivres nous avons du sang sur
les mains
c'est plus comme de l'encre nous allons  venez
des créateurs de Shaun of the Dead et
Hot Fuzz J'ai une meilleure idée de
la seule façon de survivre à la nuit,
c'est-à-dire de traverser à
nouveau la fin du monde bonjour je suis un robot
nous ne sommes que cinq amis
ayant  un bon moment
le bout du monde
[Musique]
on va arriver au bout du monde
si ça nous tue
[Musique]